Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
Welcome back to the David Pakman show, Benjamin
Dixon filling in for David while he is appearing
on the Joe Rogan podcast.
If you're visiting this video soon enough,
David, but we'll be live at 3:00 PM on Joe
Rogan's, uh, channel youtube channel.
Um, and if you're watching this video at a
later point, then obviously go and watch the
replay.
I'm sure it's going to be a fascinating conversation
filed this next video.
Um, this next story under being so committed
to your racism, um, that it backfires.
A 70 year old ruby how has been arrested.
She was first fired and that she was arrested.
Um, as a result of a video that went viral,
they showed her pulling a gun on two black
people, uh, as they, uh, attended our try
to find a place to have a picnic ruby nail.
How is a 70 year old white woman and a, the
video really speaks volumes about so many
things that still have to be discussed today.
Take a look at the video.
This lady literally just pulled the gun because
we are here and they have reservation all
like that.
We didn't even know we had hair reservation
for what are known as [inaudible].
You had been with tellers?
We did.
We've got no man, we didn't know.
Dot.
They had to do was tell us to, we would have
lit up.
You do not have to pull the Garmin
really
well that's, that's all you had to say.
That's all you have to say.
Okay, well that's fine.
That's fine.
No, I mean it's, it's really impossible to
look at that video and not discuss it in the
broader context of so many things that are
still happening in this country, but very
specifically the history of this country,
the, um, the, the historical baggage, uh,
the racial baggage that still exist in this
country.
I mean, it's, I have to discuss it in that
context, uh, because look at how shockingly
quick this escalated to a life threatening
situation for this black couple who basically
just went out to look for a place to barbecue.
Um, she pulled a gun because, um, they weren't
supposed to be there.
Well Ruby Nail how works for that camp site
and she no longer works there, but she did.
And I'm quite sure that's not the first time
someone had came to looking to use their facilities
without an appointment.
I mean, quite frankly, most people when you're
looking for a place to barbecue, you look
for a public space and you just go there and
then you find out, you know, by, okay, it's,
it's, it's, it's free to use it.
I don't need an appointment or you need a
permit and you need an appointment.
But in none of the situations that I've ever
encountered that remotely similar to this,
and I'm sure for you as well, a matter of
fact, I would guarantee 99% of everyone listening,
probably 100% of everyone listening.
If you encounter a situation where you showed
up somewhere where you needed a permit, are
you needed, uh, to make an appointment?
Nobody pulled a gun out on you, um, to demonstrate,
uh, that you didn't have the right to be there.
But Ruby nail how of Starkville Mississippi
thought that that was the right thing to do.
And so not only did she lose her job, but
she also was arrested on, um, for threatening
exit four, eight threatening exhibition of
a weapon.
Uh, she was, she turned herself in and got
out on a whopping $500 bond.
Now, um, I again, I, I don't really want to
Belabor the point too much, but, uh, you have
to put a fine point on this fact.
In some states she would have been better
off if she had killed that couple.
And as inflammatory as that statement sounds,
you have to understand states like Florida
and Georgia have stand your ground laws, um,
that allows a person to use weapons to a quote
unquote defend themselves when they fear for
their life and they have the right to stand
their ground.
Um, which, which really I bring it up because
you have to ask yourself the question, at
what point is the unreasonable, an irrational
fear of black people, uh, going to be addressed
in situations like this, but more specifically
in situations where people stand their ground.
Because this woman had literally no reason
whatsoever to fear this couple, no reason
whatsoever to pull a gun on this couple.
But she poured it out.
I mean, for whatever.
I mean, she, she, you have to say she was
afraid, right?
You don't just put a, unless you're pulling
out the gun just to, you know, just for a
power play, uh, well that backfired for as
well.
But there's an irrational level of fear that,
that is connected to black people.
And that's intentional.
I mean, I can break this down so many different
ways and come to my channel and, and, and
I'll do that.
But that's intentional.
Like this irrational fear that would lead
this woman to pull a gun on a couple, a married
couple, not that, that should be a qualifier.
And then, Oh, if they're not married or if
they weren't a couple of, they should have
had it.
No, no, no.
But still it's a, you know, a married couple
looking to have a barbecue and there's woman
either just wanted to show how bad she was,
our, she had some irrational fear going on
and led to her pulling the gun out.
Thank goodness she didn't use it.
But in so many cases we see across the country
those weapons are used and people lose their
lives because of this irrational fear that
has been baked into this American societies.
The vilification of blackness goes all the
way back to the justification for slavery
because there had to have be the, had to have
been a level of dehumanization that took place
for people to justify and say, oh, and for
particularly for Christians in this country
to say, Oh, well slavery, even though, uh,
you know it, it's okay because they're not
really human.
It trickles down through generations.
It's this fear is irrational fear.
I'm going to get off of this one and just
move on to something funny.
But this irrational fear trickles down through
the generations and it is still here today.
And we see incidents like this that could
really have led to the death of people for
no reason whatsoever based on some irrational
fear that is baked into this American system.